Please welcome co-founder and CEO at
the nuclear company, Jonathan Webb.
[Music]
Just let this sink in for a moment. That
pink line is the US. That blue line is China.
We still have the largest nuclear operating fleet
in the world. But if you see that trajectory,
that's about to change. And it's unacceptable.
We're all here talking about AI. There's
no AI without power. And the most stable
power in the world is nuclear power.
It was invented right here in the US.
Our grandparents, our parents,
they built stuff in the 60s and 70s that's
still powering 20% of the country today.
In the last 30 years, we built two reactors.
Those two reactors were just recently finished.
They were budgeted at $14 billion.
They came in at $36 billion.
10,000 people on the construction site working to
execute that job, managing it with paper. We're
the largest economy in the world. We talk about
innovation and we're giving our frontline teams
wagons and wheelbarls of paper. No more. So the
nuclear company a few years ago formed with the
sole purpose in life to deploy nuclear safer,
higher quality and faster and lower cost than
anywhere in the world. We have a lot of companies
in the US right now designing reactors. Those are
all great reactor types. The reactor is not the
problem. About 20 to 30% of the total project
cost of a nuclear power plant is the reactor.
Legacy designs in the US are incredible. Some
of the highest operating performance around
the world. The new designs coming to market
are going to be incredible. The problem is we
need to be able to deploy those reactors at a
scale that's almost unconscionable for this room.
We have a president that set out a goal to build
300 gigawatts by 2050. That's a goal to keep us
up with the demand of advanced manufacturing,
electrification of everything into this room. AI,
I just told you two reactors cost $ 36 billion,
took 10,000 people on a construction site. How are
we going to slash that? My client's the frontline
worker. Probably got some investors and bored
watching today. I don't work for you. I work
for that man and woman waking up at 3:00 a.m. in
a construction trailer. And it's our job to give
them tools and technology to win. We can't just
talk about the American spirit and not give our
people the technology they need. With Palunteer,
we're going to do that. And we're doing it in a
way that's going to completely shock this world.
Right here, what you're looking at is mission
control. So, the same way you're launching rockets
into space, we're going to we we're designing a
control room where our essentially SEAL team
six, our best operators are going to be they're
going to be managing that project virtually from
from afar. As we have multiple projects going,
we're going to be looking at the the budget,
productivity, everything is running through
that data lake. That data lake is going to have
LLMs and AI on top of it. My frontline teams,
those men and women waking up at 3:00 a.m. in
a construction trailer are going to be getting
predictive analytics. Supply chains delayed
the night before. We need you to redirect. We
have corrective action quality control from
the day before. We need to redirect teams.
Zooming from project from mission control down
to project. You're zooming in fleets across the
country. Now we've got localized construction
teams. Me and my wife got engaged on the last
construction site. It's unacceptable the
way we're building here in this country.
It's unacceptable. We're going to show you
what a modern construction site looks like.
You're going to come into our construction
trailers. It's going to look like this. Not
a bunch of paper on the floor. And we're
going to take that budget and we're going
to slash it in half. We're going to take that
time. We're going to slash it in half. We're
going to take the people from 10,000 down to
5,000. And we can do this with technology.
It's this worker first mentality. My client is the
frontline employee. How can I reduce the friction
from their life? How can I take every piece of
element that they need to worry about every day
away so that they're getting predictive analytics
in real time? Construction foreman, we're going to
have drones with LAR. Welds are off. What might
have taken 3 weeks to find welds that are off,
drone will find it. They're going to let the
construction foreman know in an earpiece in
real time immediately. We're going to take
teams corrective action. redo those welds.
What might have cost tens of millions, if not
more, in weeks or months in delay can be done
in hours. Why are we building stuff like we live
in 1985? Well, we're not going to traceability,
full traceability, full transparency. This nuclear
industry, all you're going to hear about is
everybody blaming the regulator. It's the victim,
biggest victim Eeyore industry I've ever seen. The
regulator is not our problem. We have the safest
nuclear on planet Earth. You know how many people
have died in the US of of nuclear radiation due
to due to power plants? 0.0 ever. That's because
of our regulator. We're going to give them radical
transparency in real time. All the data we have,
let them come in in real time and challenge us
on how we can get better. Every decision we make,
every change we make will be in that data
repository. the last project that was built
down in Georgia, hundreds of thousands of pages of
documents managing the project with paper. Later
this month or next month, uh there's a state here
in the US that is about to select an awardee to
go finish what is going to be about a 20 billion
nuclear power plant, a site that got abandoned
uh and was unable to be completed. The state might
pick us. So, I hope you know I we've we've shown
them our capabilities. In less than two years,
because of Palunteer, because of this technology,
and because of the team I've been able to
hire to partner with the Palunteer team,
we are confident we can give those frontline
employees not only the tools and that Iron Man
suit to go build on time, on budget, but we're
going to do it in the safest possible way.
The stakes are too high. If you're a sports
fan, we're in the fourth quarter, you know,
we're in that that second
inning or the ninth inning.
Our children, that American dream we talk about,
it's fading. And China is just beating us. They
are winning. So to all the tech bros and
all the big CEOs at Fortune 500 companies,
it's time for us to work together, leave our
ego at the door, be a little bit humbled,
and understand that it is possible, but right
now we have a long hill to climb. We're not
only going to build these power plants low cost
and fast. These these are power plants that are
going to last a hundred years. They're going
to outlive me and my team and my grandkids or
kids or your kids are going to be benefiting
from the work we're doing. Thank you to the
Palunteer team for supporting what we're
doing and and look forward to inviting you
all onto our construction site later this
year, early next year. Thank you. [Music]